IT IS A COVER.
IT IS A DIVERSION TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE FROM GETTING RICH FROM
THE BIGGEST SCAMS OF ALL.
AMERICA’S CORE PROBLEMS ARE IN
FACT ECONOMIC.
CAN YOUR KIDS EARN ENOUGH TO
PERK -- FORMED STABLE FAMILIES
HAVE THEIR OWN AND LIVE IN
DIGNITY?
THAT’S WHAT MOST AMERICANS OF
ALL COLOR WORRY ABOUT MOST SO OF
COURSE IT IS THE ONE THING THE
LEADERS HATE TO TALK ABOUT.
THAT IS NOT ACCIDENTAL.
IT IS BY DESIGN.
WHAT WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS
DISGUISED AS RACE WAR.
THE POPULATION AT ONE ANOTHER’S
THROATS ANGRY, SUSPICIOUS,
TRIBAL AND EVER FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH WE ARE STEALING.
THE BIGGEST CHANGE TO AMERICAN
SOCIETY OVER THE PAST 50 YEARS
HAS BEEN THE DEATH OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
THIS USED TO BE THE MIDDLE-CLASS
COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT ANYMORE.
MOST OF THE POPULATION HAS
BECOME POOR IN REAL TERMS.
A SHRINKING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
CONTROLLING EVERY EXPANDING
PERCENTAGE OF THE WEALTH.
THAT MEANS THAT FEWER AMERICANS
OVERALL HAVE A MEANINGFUL STAKE
IN SOCIETY AND MORE ARE
DEPENDENT.
THAT MAKES THE COUNTRY MUCH MORE
VOLATILE THAN IT ONCE WAS.
THESE RIOTS REALLY SHOULDN’T
SURPRISE YOU.
IT IS HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SAD
CHANGES TO AMERICA, BUT IT IS
EASY TO SEE WHO IS BENEFITING
FROM THEM HERE THEY ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE LECTURING YOU ABOUT WHITE
PRIVILEGE AND SYSTEMIC RACISM.
THIS ISN’T ACCIDENTAL.
CITIBANK IS HAPPY TO PUT BLACK
LIVES MATTER LOGOS ON THEIR
INSTAGRAM PAGE PRECISELY SO YOU
WON’T ASK WHAT INTEREST RATES
THEY ARE CHARGING BLACK PEOPLE.
IF YOU REALLY CARED ABOUT THE
POOR, YOU WOULDN’T CRUSH THEM
WITH DEBT THEY CAN’T AFFORD TO.
OF COURSE IF YOU REALLY CARED
ABOUT BLACK LIVES, YOU WOULDN’T
PUT ABORTION CLINICS IN BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT THEY DO.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SCAM ARTISTS.